he's still hunting for that first goal of the
preseason and The Bard line starts things out
Taylor Hall and Tyler Johnson on the wings that
one bangs around for janathan berren for Detroit
he takes a hit alongside the Blackhawks bench from
Taylor radish and the Hawks try and exit the Zone
much quicker than they did on Sunday night and
Lucas reel pounces on the puck in the attacking
Zone makes a move and whoo shuts him down many
more veterans in the lineup tonight on home ICE
including Nick phino and Cory Perry who are on the
ice right now in a line that is centered by Jason
Dickinson who takes the puck beeds Felino whoo
the save rebound whacked at by Barry and the Hawks
score it's a pretty good grinder line I love the
way Dickinson comes in with some Jam Causes Chaos
in front of the net and then who else but Cory
Perry from his office 5 feet in front of the net
to get that rebound put it between the legs of
the net minder and get the Hawks on the board
first great start for the Blackhawks tonight he's
not afraid to to pay the price in front of the net
like that the way aim did for the Hawks Taylor
Hall Scoops the puck up The Bard line on the ice
Tyler Johnson a rip rebound loose just does a
really nice job using the width of the ice and
getting it all the way across to Tyler Johnson
having to make Billy huso come across the crease
he recognizes that early and gets himself in a
great position but I love the idea from Tyler
Johnson Alex blassic download defensively berren
throws it off the glass berren again through the
crease it knocks back behind morazzi Clen C
former Edmonton Oiler now berren feno knocked
Away by morazzi Taylor Hall the rebound ducet
alongside the net throws it through the blue
paint raford e to the point Johansson lots of
traffic in front now it clears and mazic gives
up the rebound on the shot from rery duet over
to Johansson morazzi another save Cory Perry
to the puck for the Hawks moric hasn't had to
see a ton of action but he has been a really
calm presence back there and made some timely
saves here in the second half of the game when
he's needed to uh the fourth line bottom six
forwards for Detroit right now that are making
it hard on the Blackhawks late in this first
period duet still on the ice a shove from Seth
Jones will send him to the bench finally an
artanim Mo denied by moric oh what a save by
Peter fun fact he and stabber another goenda
Hawks both got their NHL starts against the St
Louis Blues and Peter mzik said he could still
tell tell you what his room number was at the
Weston his first year I'll do the same I'll try
and get him after the game tonight just about a
minute into the second period and here's janathan
berren for the Red Wings working around Alex
classic feno snaps one off and scores wow beIN
to valeno and the wings have tied it up get low
to high goes underneath the Stick of Seth Jones on
the way to the net blasic does his best to try to
contain this but valeno just slips in finds some
soft ice and perfectly places that one against
Peter mazic who's got a stretch all the way from
right to left Moone drop for Chicago Lucas reel
takes it wins it Alex blasic covered up by Joel
esparon Reichel throws it through the crease and
Tyler Johnson couldn't find it it rebounds out
again and Johnson just missed a second try after
it slipped in from radish Tyler Johnson's been
around the puck all game Reichel can't quite jump
that route ducet shovels it ahead to a ni Mo on
the counter mazic the sa two preseason meetings
two regular season meetings on the schedule
between these two as Murphy shot that's a
score tucked just underneath the crossbar there's
a goal from a defenseman and the Hawks grabb the
lead what a beautiful shot right off a nice set
play off the face off takes his time picks his
Corner top shelf and beats Hutchinson glove side
he may have been cheating a little bit to the left
but Murphy does a nice job baiting him and just
pulling that stick in a little bit tighter to
change the angle of it and he elevates the puck
down into Detroit's end Conor Bard here he goes
he's shut down by Hutchinson Bard looking for his
first preseason lamp lighter and he nearly had it
and a penalty coming up here oh what a save
by Hutchinson he thought for sure that was it
forehand backand goes right back to his forehand
tries to beat him maybe needed to elevate that
puck a little bit but Hutchinson does a great job
staying with him and he does draw the penalty so
let's see if the Hawks power play can go back to
work here just not quite there that was fortunate
for kinsky to pick the puck up as Justin Hall
came out of the box for Detroit now koutuk for Ed
whistle off the post poor an whistle snake bitten
tonight that was really good offense nice job like
I said starting with that second power play unit
they kind of had Detroit on their heels a little
bit there it's a Grace cross ice pass and whistle
looking for the tap in back door and just misses
we've got third period action coming your
way next when am I when am I going to get
actually get to try this Kaye have you a good
sip I took a full one it was delicious is it
good I'll be there yes okay get the Pu off
quickly and on net getting it through for
him is going to be key Joe voleno Justin Hall
in front Barren was there Murphy on defense
clim cson off Alex vasic valeno hangs on to
the puck in the ozone trying to shake Lucas
reel clim C back to Baleno and the [Applause]
score a give and go for Detroit they tie it up
in the third he's down low by the hashmarks
he's got to be supportive it just a second
too late there breakdown defensively allows them
to get in and get that shot shot off in the high
slot and it's a great quick play right there
by Detroit but that extra second you lose a
guy that's how quickly you can get burned there
and mirazic had no idea Seth Jones over to Bard
Perry throws it through Seth Jones Bard wants it
shoots it it's blocked away like cheating over
to vard Taylor Hall open Cory Perry is second
of the night Hawks grabb the lead three to2 in
the [Applause] third you know Cory Perry was
left alone a couple of times as soon as Seth
Jones and Taylor Hall made themselves a threat
to score it's just a great idea you've got a left
shot to a righty across the crease that's one of
the looks they're looking for against Hutchinson
and you know Cory Perry can bury anything in and
around that blue paint beautiful goal Bard picks
the puck up flips to Seth Jones back to Bard
black Perry Bard Bard looking for an opening
knocked Away by Hutchinson haul to the puck and
it Glides down to Peter morazzi sna back to Bard
Red Wings change Bard still on the ice Bard on an
open net his first goal with the Blackhawks in the
pre-season but his very first of
the preseason and it's going to
be an assist from Peter morazzi all
the way in net and all the way down
finally it's Bard who gets that one in
after several attempts on the empty net
98 gets it done I don't think he's very
happy no I I think bad ears on my end way
off much different performance for
the Blackhawks against the Red Wings
tonight different rosters for both teams largely